[Captions by Mike R. at Y Translator]
I kinda want to try just doing
a big, scaled-up version of that
where I just get, like,
a gallon of oil
boiling and on fire, then pouring, like,
a gallon of water onto it.
I don't know if this dome
would be big enough
to contain that fireball, honestly.
That would be a lot of fire.
Hey, guys, I'm Nate.
Welcome back to the dome, where,
as you can probably see by my breath,
it's pretty chilly.
Today, we've got another fun experiment.
Salt and oil are usually things that
go really well together on foods.
Today, we're gonna see if
they go really well together
when the salt is 1800º Fahrenheit.
We're gonna melt down some salt
until it's nice and liquid,
and then we're gonna pour
that superhot salt
onto three different types of oil
to see how it reacts.
We've got some standard liquid cooking oil,
we've got some butter
and then we've got some motor oil.
We're gonna try pouring molten salt into
all three of those and see what happens.
The flash point, or the point
where these oils should light on fire,
is well below the melting temperature of salt.
So, we might be able
to get these to light on fire.
Let's find out.
Let's fill our crucible with
salt and fire up the furnace.
That looks like a good amount of salt.
Here we go.
We're gonna start using our cooking oil,
and while our salt is
just finishing up melting in the foundry,
we'll fill our pot.
Now, I don't think that pouring salt into oil
will have any large splashing or explosive effects.
But as a precaution,
I am wearing this jacket.
I'm gonna even put the hood up,
I'll have glasses on,
and I'll have
my thick leather welding gloves.
Like I said, I
don't think it will explode.
I hope it'll light on fire.
We'll find out.
Whew! Look at that.
That is some toasty salt.
All right, here we go.
3, 2, 1.
All right. That lit on fire
just exactly like I was expecting it to,
but I did not see
the formation of the salt coming at all.
Look at the shape of that.
It's like coral or something in there.
That is wild.
That is so weird. Wow!
Also, it kind of smells like
we're cooking now, cuz, you know,
salt and oil together,
that's not unpleasant.
Look at at that shape.
I hope I can get that all out
in one piece from the pot.
It might be a little bit fragile
so it might break when I try,
but man, that is cool.
Also, the oil is just still on fire.
It's kind of interesting because
most of the oil, I think,
is not hot enough to be burning,
but it lit the surface on fire,
and so we'll see.
Maybe that's now heating it up even more.
It's hard to tell.
I haven't lit a whole lot of oil on fire.
Maybe it's something I need to play with.
But, yeah, this is pretty cool.
Let's see if it will blow out.
Hmm.
I think the moisture from my breath
makes it angry.
It does not want to blow out.
What do you think?
Should I pour some water on it?
Of course, I should.
I'm gonna pour some water on it.
Hah! That was great.
Nice, little fireball.
I love the way that traveled up like that.
That looked really good.
And interestingly, it did put the fire out.
Actually, I think it was that
the fire went into a fireball
It might have burned up all the oxygen,
so there was no more for it to be burning,
but I don't really know.
But in the end, it looked cool.
No one got splattered.
Nice little tower fireball.
And now the fires out,
so we can try and take our chunk
of weirdly shaped salt out.
There we go.
That is what happens to our molten
salt when I poured it into the cooking oil.
And I will tell you, there were many things
I thought might happen.
It never occurred to me
that this would happen.
Now, I'm curious if it will do that
with the other kinds of oil.
We've also started to fry our board a little bit
because our oil is still very toasty.
Fried wood. Mmm.
Next up, we're going to see what happens
if we pour our molten salt onto butter.
Now, this isn't going to start as a liquid,
so I'm sure we'll have
something of a different result.
I don't even know
what it is that's igniting.
All right.
There you go.
Molten salt onto butter in 3, 2, 1.
That's a lot of thick smoke.
I think most of the flames went out,  though.
I hear it bubbling a lot.
Now butter has a lot more water in it.
Butter isn't as pure of an oil as cooking
oil.
It has a lot of other
chemicals and materials in it.
That smells really good.
Smells like something delicious cooking.
Boy, that is some boiling oil right there.
Still going.
It's been there for like a minute and a half.
So, it's obviously very hot.
But I'm curious if it's flammable.
So, I'm gonna hit that with the blowtorch
and see if it'll ignite.
Nope. Something's bubbling and boiling,
but it's not lighting on fire.
Our butter didn't light on fire
the same way or cooking oil did,
but it did boil a lot.
And I think that's because there are
some non-oil components to butter.
I think the milk fat
that butter is made from
still has water in it –
something like that –
and now it's just boiling,
and that's why it didn't ignite.
But I'm curious to see what happened
to the salt on this one.
So, I'm gonna dispose of the butter
and then see what the salt
underneath it's looking like.
All righ. So, I poured off the melted butter.
And you can see where the two lower blocks
of butter were still in the pan.
So we've got the salt that poured down
melting the top two bricks of butter,
and the bottom two took longer to melt,
and so, I think the salts
solidified around those two blocks.
So we just have the two gaps
where they were.
Then, of course, they melted,
as well, from the heat.
Salt number one. Salt number two.
Well, we've got one more
kind of oil to try,
so, let's melt up some more salt,
try it on that.
We're gonna be doing this with motor oil.
3, 2, 1.
And it's on fire.
Excellent.
Well, the motor oil lit on fire,
very similar to how the cooking oil did,
making some nice boiling,
bubbling action there, too.
I can't really see what the salt has done.
It hasn't reacted the same way.
We don't have the large
coil-looking formations
that we did with the cooking oil.
Hard to tell what we do have going on.
It doesn't smell as good
as it did with the butter.
That smelled really good.
I think we have the oil
now vaporizing and burning.
Ahh. [LAUGHS] it's just so warm,
it reignited itself.
Interesting how different those turned out.
I definitely like the one
from the cooking oil the best.
That's fun.
This has now cooled off.
So this is salt that cooled down in butter.
Pretty good.
A little burned tasting,
but I can taste butter
and I can taste salt,
and that's a good combo.
But it also tastes like burning.
That part's not great.
I'm not going to try licking that one.
Frankly, I'm not too interested
in trying to lick that one either,
although it does look just really neat.
Molten salt poured into
three different types of oil.
We've tried pouring it into cooking oil,
we tried pouring it onto butter,
and we tried pouring it onto motor oil.
The cooking oil and motor oil
both burst into flames
almost immediately and stayed burning.
The butter lit on fire very briefly,
but then was put out,
and I think that's by all of
the non-oil solids and liquids
that might make up the butter.
It was very fun throwing
a little bit of water
onto our oil fires and, of course,
that, explodes.
And you should never do that anywhere
that could catch things on fire –
like a kitchen, or
most places at your house,
or anywhere that isn't
a concrete dome with a dirt floor.
This is a very safe place
to burn things and, even so,
I was careful to be wearing gloves,
long sleeves, a hood, glasses,
thick pants, everything
to keep myself protected.
I think by far, the most surprised
I was at this whole experiment
was what happened to the salt
when we poured it into the cooking oil,
how full of something, I don't know,
air, or bubbles, or oil,
or something that the salt got
when we poured it into our canola oil,
that part surprised me.
Overall, I'm glad to have learned
that salt does not explode on contact
with oil or anything like that,
but it does catch it on fire.
And that's always fun.
Hey guys, thanks for watching.
If you're not a subscriber yet,
just hit the bomb to get into the club.
If you missed our last video
or want to see it again,
click up here at the top.
Click down there if you want to see what the
Internet thinks that you should watch next.
That's it for now.
Have fun, be safe,
and see you tomorrow.
[PUNCHING SOUND]